this is a CBS News special report I'm
telling you two couple in New York the
Labor Department has just released
another huge set of weekly jobless
claims more than 22 million Americans
have filed for unemployment since
mid-march showing the historic economic
impact of the coronavirus CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us now so Joe for four weeks now we've
seen a torrent of job losses we're
getting new numbers in right at this
moment what are they are we adding to
that misery unfortunately yes another
4.4 million Americans have filed claims
so now we're up at around 26 million
Americans now the numbers are tapering
off just a little bit it looks like we
hit a peak in late March early April but
let's be clear this is a huge number of
people and already we now know according
to the Labor Department 16 million
people are actually receiving
unemployment benefits as we speak so
these are just astounding and as you
said really sad and awful numbers so Joe
some states are beginning to think about
reopening some businesses at least and
the White House would like to suggest
that we could see a so-called v-shaped
recovery steep downturn rapid return is
that still in the cars you also hear
about a w-shaped recovery what's the
difference and what's it looking like
well let's talk about V versus W so a V
as you said we would be going sharply
lower then bounce from that I think that
that's a little ambitious what a W
really means is that you have a sharp
down a slight up and then data turn down
again it's also known as a double-dip
recession and here's the fear among
economists that if we go back too
quickly to work that we are more likely
to see a second leg down and what's
really critical about a second leg down
is that it's harder for consumers and
businesses to come out of that second
leg we are obviously human beings we get
excited or optimistic when on the way up
we get downtrodden on the way lower and
that
and really stall an economic growth
period so we're worried about going to
back too quickly there's a report among
a bunch of Federal Reserve economists
that went back to the flu of 1918 and
that report has found that those
municipalities that actually had tougher
rules about going back to work actually
emerged better economically over the
long term
so maybe 100 year ago history might be
well worth revisiting today alright Joe
thank you very much we now have five
weeks of coronavirus related jobless
claims and they total roughly 26 million
Americans cumulative lis the
unemployment rate is estimated in April
to be about 15 percent to find a rate
that high you have to go all the way
back to the Great Depression